This is part number 3.
I am explaining the 3 new plans that real madrid has released for madridistas.
Com I am going to explain madridistas premium which
is like the successor of the old madridistas card.
This plan can be taken by anyone.
This card is physical unlike the previously mentioned ones.
They send you the club's magazine that I will put it here last year's.
And the most important benefits is above all access to buy tickets
before the general public because when the general public arrives
the tickets are sold out with this you can buy them and you have
some left later you have a discount on the tour of the bernabeu
that now that it is under construction is luxury to be able to visit it.
You get a discount on basketball tickets on non-football tickets
and you also get a discount at the club's official store for jerseys,
merchandising and stuff like that.
And you're going to subscribe some tell me in the comments I read it.